engineers in California this morning are
struggling to develop a plan to remove
huge amounts of debris after a
devastating landslide more than a
million tons of coastline gave way about
two weeks ago it cut off the scenic
Pacific Coast Highway and pushed the
rock in the earth about 600 feet into
the Pacific Ocean John Blackstone is in
ragged point that's about ten miles
south of the landslide with this ongoing
threat John good morning good morning
well this roadblock here on California's
highway 1 is causing disappointment for
thousands of tourists and hardship for
dozens of businesses but the landslide
that has closed this scenic road is a
monster that is still growing the gash
on the hillside is more than 1/3 of a
mile wide tumbling into the ocean and
there's more waiting to come down are we
walking on a potential slope we are
walking on an active landslide Caltrans
engineer Doug Cook showed us where
cracks in the land indicate this
hillside is still slipping start small
start slowly little big the ongoing
movement of the slide is being measured
by ground sensors like these and radar
that continually scans the hillside a
USGS animation shows how more than a
million tons of rock and earth came down
pushing some 15 acres of new land 600
feet into the sea from here this massive
landslide stretches more than 1,800 feet
across more than a thousand feet high
and it's still moving so unstable
engineers haven't yet figured out how to
even begin rebuilding this road that
clings to the coastline a hundred fifty
feet above the ocean it was cut in
eighty years ago by hand but it was cut
through large masses of unstable ground
unusually heavy rain this winter
triggered other landslides as well
bringing down a bridge at the northern
end of Big Sur
closing more than 50 miles of highway
one that has left tourist businesses
there almost completely cut off the one
way in for visitors is by air but even
that's not certain when we tried to fly
in fog blocked our landing okay let's go
that left one other option a nearly
mile-long hike
Kirk Gathol president of the Big Sur
Chamber of Commerce was our guide so
this is the only trail access in from
north to south for local residents
Gothel is general manager of Nepenthe a
a big sur restaurant with spectacular
views but these days almost no customers
so that trade-off for this really
amazing location is a certain fragility
of access now every once in a while we
lose it and we have to work our way
around it and that's what we're
challenged with today the bridge that's
out could be replaced by late September
but the landslide that's up this road
could take more than a year to fix but
tourists should be aware that parts of
highway 1 to the north and south are
open and there are still some
spectacular views to be seen along this
road Noora and that's the silver lining
John thank you so much